CSS in this style dot CSS file you won't
be learning CSS in this class but if you
want to learn more check out the link in
the instructors notes CSS is pretty
simple as we can see over here it's
simply defining the styles of the page
so what about this not a jQuery file
that you wanted to tell them about yeah
jQuery it's a powerful and popular
JavaScript library that we'll be using
in this class at a very high level and
lets us inspect and manipulate the
elements in a page you won't be learning
the ins and outs of jQuery in this class
but you'll get an idea of what you can
do with some very basic jQuery functions
for more information about jQuery check
out the link in the instructors notes
the things were done with jQuery are
fairly simple and can be done with the
knowledge out script as well just like
we're doing in the script tag at the
bottom of the HTML page but we wanted
you to gain experience with using
third-party libraries when appropriate
we will also list the vanilla JavaScript
ways to do things in the instructors
notes